they were in the middle of a run serious
[Music]
what's poppin welcome to my new crib
look at that I just bought off my
bitcoins so what we're doing is we're
doing work from home Fridays I can't
speak too loudly right now because you
know most of the people are sleeping
it's actually 7:00 a.m. now but you know
me and that's all about the grind so I
woke up pretty early got I'm gonna call
my videos and stuff like that but yeah
alright let me just give you a tour as
you can see this is a review this is our
balcony damps alright and it is the
living area that's earth to the kitchen
I think they recently had a party in
here Arius I gotta go wake up my friends
cuz uh I kind of want to go skiing early
let's go
let's go yeah I'm gonna have butter
jelly sandwich I think I think I played
out your question or something because
like now that I'm just gonna state email
[Music]
yeah what are you doing I just got they
were in the middle of a run are you
serious
should I needs a hot spot [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
just imagine I told you machinist aaaah
holy [ __ ] this is absurd doesn't your
major know you're in Tahoe [ __ ] you know
working from oh yeah from home
oh [ __ ] VPN
[Music]
holy [ __ ] how am I supposed to this this
is so wet always supposed to type on
this oh my god Oh awesome thank you so
much
yeah you're the best well I've never had
a kiss before my life
my hands are so cold
typing and also the color is really hard
to see should I'm so stressed bro I'm
super stressed look at my keyboard is in
there slash snow in here here we good
like for depth but for one part of it
it's good
alright anyways we're gonna go back to
skiing later but right now we're just
gonna do that so I'm gonna skip all this
part hey see you later yeah what are you
doing
reception here okay better I can
actually hotspot yeah just something
about the left oh gotta do what you
gotta do to make your make your p.m.
happy all right
look who is using my laptop right now
what are you doing right now
who did you laugh at me when I brought
my laptop
that's good foresight see you're owe me
one now did you even bring your own
laptop now his manager is up on his ass
so now he's working there you go see I
think ahead
you know you last now it like you
laughed before but there you go I'm
actually alright hey what's it a while
meanwhile back at home we see software
engineers in their natural habitat
working really hard to produce their
quality code the laces of the pack
decided to bake cookies I was quickly
denied of that look
darn it
not again good morning yours was popping
for breakfast what the [ __ ] that's a
weird combo yeah jumping eggs yellow
brothers for what are those jesse is so
bored are you having fun Jesse so how
big are you
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's poppin look at this beautiful
view my god I'm my friend Cyrus again
how you doing yeah today's a lot more
chill cuz it's Saturday so I definitely
did not need to work today so that's why
I don't have a backpack I don't have my
laptop but then again my laptop's broken
so I can't work anyways but holy [ __ ]
check what I did to my laptop
absolutely beautiful
oh yeah I guess I'm gonna say I might as
well say it now so as you know I said
last time that I was gonna give a
giveaway at 2500 subscribers 5,000 and
10,000 25,000 and I miss all of those so
that's why I am doing for giveaways whoo
get excited unfortunately not air pause
this time I can't afford air pause
anymore but I'm gonna do a free giveaway
for my merch so that means I'm gonna
pick four winners and I'm gonna give you
the detail later probably like not now
cuz I can't think of anything so it's
probably gonna be follow me on instagram
follow me on twitter and then write a
question for me and the best questions
will get free merch and what else and
then also like send me a video of a make
Joe my parody hit water
if you want to buy him water use my
sponsor code pornhub.com slash jumu tech
[Music]
hey Joe my parody or something like that
and that the best one will also get free
merch but yeah so I'll give you probably
like a coupon if you buy any one of the
merch I'm just gonna try to design more
of them but I think so far just like a
few of them and they're pretty cool but
yeah
yeah show me show me show me that show
me that 180 bro whoa barely 90 no that
was not past 90 alright so I am uh I'm
teaching son me how to snowboard I am a
great teacher I want to prove to the
world what a great teacher I am what do
you have to say all the time it's not
because I suck at DJ's because she sucks
at learning no I want to show the world
war a great teacher area so you better
not [ __ ] up
excellent excellent and then you break
don't be afraid because I think it's all
mental how does it feel how's your first
time snowboarding higher okay
that's good it means you're using it
like your legs all right get up no
wonder why your butts so flat there you
go stop being sideways go straight
I can't I missed it I missed it actually
I didn't film you faceplant
so you're lucky yeah let's go faster
can't start doing on just like like oh
no like yeah I like don't move your
thing don't don't break just just stay
until until you're too afraid like now's
a good time to start like this that's
good that's good nice vlogging skills
you getting really good
[Laughter]
there you go alright so yeah we're just
gonna take a food break and here's three
wieners let's get out space for food but
you know what can you do we can do it's
cost like 45 bucks I think it's like 15
bucks per sausage what a beautiful day
beautiful blue sky and that's on me
trying to get up for like 25 minutes oh
my god every run takes like 30 minutes
it's cuz you're too lazy feelings track
because Sunmi is actually doing really
well right now
I think I'm just gonna vlog a little bit
talk about my life yeah so okay a lot of
the questions I hear I hear about like
what coding language or what kind what
kind of area you should focus on but in
the end I think coding language don't
matter it's all about fundamentals it's
all about fundamentals so like for
example coding right like in my mind PHP
C++ whatever if you write normal code or
whatever you have in like those coding
questions it's already so simple it's
almost any like loops for loops but for
loops and stuff like that and a lot of
people ask me what language to learn but
that doesn't really matter because it's
better to learn like 50 fundamentals and
algorithms and just understand how to
build products and then the reason why
you would choose a language is either
they're already libraries or already
frameworks or because they're working
for a company that's using that language
anyways and then that's where you would
maybe learn a little bit more of
language but most of the big companies
they don't they only care
[Music]
[Music]
hey what's coffin I'm Joe mom we're done
for the weekend Thank You Jennifer for
the intro now thank you so much I'll
don't forget if you like this video
don't forget to subscribe and also like
the video and also follow me on the
Instagram turn off the music holy [ __ ]
man I don't want a copyright strike
anyways yeah so as I said you know
hopefully you like this vlog if you like
it more comment and then I'll probably
do more but hopefully that was fun you
get to see what I do during the weekend
that's usually not why I do join the
weekend but you know it's my it's a
highlights a highlight so yeah peace out
damn I maybe I shouldn't say that
alright peace out
Chad's it's kind of weird too ok bye
ordinary viewers up
[Music]
[Music]
now continue continue good you game good